welcome everyone to law and crime daily
I'm Brian buckmeyer records for Alec
Murdoch's cell phone and the phones of
his wife Maggie and Son Paul were the
focus of testimony on Wednesday
prosecutors are using them to establish
a timeline for the murders law and
crimes Angela Levy tells us what the
records indicate about when Paul and
Maggie likely died
prosecutors played a video for the jury
that they say destroys Alec Murdoch's
Alibi the night of the murders
this video was recorded by Paul
Murdoch's cell phone at 8 44 PM minutes
later prosecutors say Paul died at the
hands of his father why is the video so
important Alec Murdoch told law
enforcement he hadn't been to the
kennels that night but prosecutors say
his is one of three voices captured on
that recording
hey he's got a bird in his mouth
Bubba
this is a chicken
quit prosecutors say the cell phone
records show a timeline for the murders
shortly after 9 45 PM neither Maggie nor
Paul ever read another text message but
the defense says at least for Paul there
could be an explanation
someone whose battery is down to two
percent might curtail their use of the
phone
it is possible yes sir and another big
question since prosecutors say Alec
Murdock killed Paul and Maggie and then
tossed her cell phone on the side of a
road were their cell phones moving
together we previously established that
his phone and Maggie Stone were not he's
walking or not walking together is that
correct they're a nice steps recorded on
the devices together
testimony resumed after the lunch break
with the jury hearing from another law
enforcement officer for Law and crime
daily I'm Anjanette Levy in Walterboro
South Carolina
I'm drawing for today's show by my
co-host and former trial Attorney Terry
Austin as well as Matthew mangino a
criminal defense attorney Matt is there
Reasonable Doubt in the cell phone
tracking evidence or is this what
ultimately convicts Murdoch
well it appears that there is some
discrepancy uh based on what we've
learned about the cell phones and
particularly one of the issues is that
the the cell phone they're not tracking
together or moving together so if
um Alex was to throw the cell phone out
the door of his car uh they weren't
moving at the same time according to the
testimony that we heard so that is one
issue the other issue is the the
videotape if that is Alex Murdoch's
voice on the videotape that was taken
shortly before his son was murdered then
that's problematic for the defense
because that's not consistent with what
he has said has happened at least in his
interviews with the police yeah sounds
like another one of those they eye
arguments that's popping into the case
though Terry you heard the cry
examination of Lieutenant Dove regarding
the phone did they make any points
during that cross well first I just have
to say Lieutenant Dove is an amazing
witness he was cool common collected he
was honest he was credible for both the
direct and the cross and I think the
jury is appreciating that but I have to
agree with Matt I think the part where
the prosecution is going to have an
issue there is those cell phones were
not pinging and walking those steps at
the same time Maggie stopped at 8 55 at
906 apparently he was moving with his
phone so somehow they're going to have
to show that those phones were together
and I think they're going to have a hard
time with that it's gonna be an
interesting closing argument for this
case I'll tell you that but you can
follow lawn crimes Capital gavel
coverage of the Alec Murdoch trial on
our website lawncrime.com there you can
find live streams evidentiary exhibits
and expert insight
a Florida man says he lost his job after
he was featured multiple times at a
local sheriff's social media game show
segment here's an example
hello everyone I'm Sheriff Wayne Ivey of
the Brevard County Sheriff's Office and
welcome to wheel of fugitive you know
how it works all 10 people up here have
warrants for their arrest we want to get
them off the streets and safely behind
bars where they can't victimize anybody
else David game filed a lawsuit against
the Sheriff's Office and Sheriff Wayne
Ivey a Gay's picture and name were
included in three segments in 2021 but
gay was actually already in the county
jail on those dates he wasn't a fugitive
he said his employer saw him feature on
the segment and told him not to bother
showing up for work okay is suing for
fifty thousand dollars for defamation
and emotional distress
still had on lawn crime daily a man
already convicted once for killing his
wife with any piece is on trial again
will this jury make the same decision as
the last one but first a Native American
actor is accused of targeting his own
Community as police arrest him for
leading an alleged sex cult
[Music]
one of the stars of the 90s Best Picture
Winner Dancing With Wolves is under
arrest and accused of sexual abuse that
goes back decades Nathan chasing horse
who played smiles a lot in the movie is
now reportedly the leader of a cult
known as the circle according to police
reports chasing horse is accused of
sexually assaulting indigenous girls he
lives in Las Vegas with his five
so-called wives but he's accused of sex
crimes in Montana and South Dakota as
well that date back to the early 2000s
he was banished from a reservation in
Montana in 2015 over allegations of
human trafficking chasing horse
allegedly convince victims that assaults
were part of a Native American tradition
and that he was a holy Medicine Man
police say one of chasing horses wives
was offered to him as a gift when she
was 15 and he married another girl just
after she turned 16. in Las Vegas Police
have identified at least six victims
some of whom are younger than 13.
about chasing horse's home was raided
then he was arrested did that give us
any clues about the investigation and
what they may have found
well certainly they the the search
warrant and what they found uh must have
been uh productive in terms of uh
providing them with evidence to
establish probable cause to arrest him I
mean what we know here is that this is a
series of uh incidents in which he uh
was trafficking women uh that he was uh
sexually assaulting young girl some of
those sexual assaults were on tape he
was
um basically pimping some of these girls
to to his friends uh for sexual conducts
so there's so many layers to what's
alleged here and it appears that he's
just simply a con man who was who was uh
going out across several States and
putting on these healing ceremonies and
and using that the platform to bring
these young women to him and then to
exploit them so it's really a series of
serious charges and uh there will be
serious consequence absolutely military
authorities across the United States are
focusing on crimes against indigenous
women and girls can you tell us more
about that yes there's a huge mass
movement Brian because you know
indigenous women girls are twice as
likely to be assaulted than others in
other demographics and one in three of
them are going to experience some sort
of violent crime so the authorities both
in Canada and the United States and
other areas they are working together
trying to get legislation trying to get
people to be aware of what's going on
and having laws that are going to really
inflict some serious punishment against
the people who are committing these
types of crimes to protect these women
they're very very vulnerable and
hopefully these movements are going to
help that situation absolutely I've
heard some of those movements especially
back home where I'm from in Canada so
let's hope they'll get some progress
there on both sides of the Border
[Music]
welcome back to Lawton crime daily we
have a verdict in Wisconsin in the trial
of Mark Jensen on Wednesday afternoon a
jury found him guilty of killing his
wife with the help of antifreeze this
was Jensen's second stint in court he
was convicted of poisoning drugging and
smothering his wife Julie in 2008 while
serving a life sentence his conviction
was vacated in 2021 when so-called
letters from the grave used in the
original trial were ruled inadmissible
after weeks after a weeks-long trial
jurors started deliberating on Tuesday
afternoon asking to review autopsy and
crime scene photos they also requested
copies of a fire department report from
a call out to the Jensen home and notes
from Julie's position to get a better
idea of how this trial wrapped up let's
take a closer look at the prosecution's
closing argument as they put the jurors
into the shoes of the victim
so we know about December 1st we know
that's the day that Julie goes to Dr
Borman and we know that that's the day
the defendant gives her the first dose
of ethylene glycol Because by the early
morning hours of December 2nd she is
showing the symptoms of ethylene glycol
intoxication Julie called her friend
Margaret foyt on the morning of December
2nd and Julie was happier than she'd
been in weeks or months here she was
desperately sick desperately ill very
uncomfortable very very uncomfortable
but she was happy Julie was finally
getting what she'd been looking for she
was getting a supportive spouse instead
of the sadistic narcissistic Thug that
she was actually married to she thought
Mark loved her and when Mark got back
from the doctor he showed again how much
he loved her by giving her the ambient
pill
that the doctor had given had prescribed
for her and giving her another half a
dose of paroxetine and you know helping
her wash it down
with orange juice and antifreeze
on the other side of the coin the
defense laid out Julie's mental health
issues and suggested her death was
actually a suicide
Mr DeFazio the psychotherapist met with
Julie Jensen he identified the
possibility of limited postpartum
depression Mr DeFazio testified that
Julie Jensen was experiencing some
obvious mental health issues
he diagnosed her as adult situational
reactive with mixed features
he noted features of depression and
anxiety the psychiatrist Dr Newman
described her as crying all the time
having no appetite she used to enjoy
cooking and now it's just a Char those
are the notes
chronically depressed cries easily and
the blood levels tell us nothing about
whether something is a homicide or a
suicide we also heard from Dr mainland's
extraordinarily questionable study is
that almost every ethylene glycol case
that she could find
was a suicide
that's sad and it's what happened here
Matt some people might be wondering why
is it important to retry him if it's I
mean we got we ended up getting the same
verdict so why do the retrial
well the retrial had to happen because
uh there was a an appeal in which the
appellate courts found that a a letter
uh that the victim had written a letter
from the grave
um that that was prejudicial uh to
Jensen during his trial and so the
alternative would be to to set him free
uh which obviously the prosecution
wasn't going to do this they they
thought they had a strong case even
without the letter and they presented
that case to a jury and ultimately uh
were successful once again so so this
and in fact what's interesting is at a
press conference after the trial was
completed after the guilty verdict was
entered uh the prosecutor read that
letter that the jurors didn't hear in
the second trial and I think that gave
those jurors some comfort that they
probably made the right decision in this
case yeah absolutely that makes sense
Terry based on the jury's questions were
you surprised by the verdict I was not
surprised by the verdict but I was
surprised as to how fast they came to
the verdict they asked for a board and
some pencils to Mark things up and they
asked for the primary care physicians
notes so they could look at whether or
not she was depressed they asked for her
autopsy report so I thought that they
were going to really put more time into
that deliberation but apparently they
got that information and they quickly
made a decision and the guilty verdict
came back again you know well twice a
road see maybe there's an appeal down
the line and he wins another uh a trial
we'll see well police in Maryland are
offering a reward after a bizarre theft
a man stole a large gorilla statue from
in front of an antique store new
surveillance video shows the man pulling
up in his truck around 3 A.M in the
morning on January 4th the and then
cutting the cable that locked the statue
to the front of the store he then
hoisted it into the back of his truck
and took off it definitely took some
work to get the statue in there it's
made of cast iron and weighs around 200
pounds the gorilla named Murphy is a
local celebrity and well-known in the
area investigators are offering up to
ten thousand dollars for Murphy's safe
return